récemment j'ai lu une étude au sujet des
regrets avant la mort une infirmière en
soins palliatifs en australie a
interrogé et compiler ce que les
personnes regrettent le plus avant de
mourir quatre grands regrets reviennent
toujours ne pas avoir eu le courage de
vivre ses rêves avoir travaillé trop dur
ne pas être resté plus en contact avec
ses amis ne pas avoir réussi à exprimer
ses sentiments après cette lecture j'ai
fait ce que tout le monde ferait je me
suis demandé et si je mourais maintenant
est ce que j'aurai ses regrets
alors j'ai constaté qu'il y avait au
moins un regret que je n'aurais pas
celui de ne pas avoir vécu mes rêves
parce que depuis que je suis petit j'ai
envie de savoir de découvrir d'essayer
de tenter cette façon de penser me
pousse à avoir une vie que beaucoup
qualifient raid aventure hier voire d'
instable pour certains or dans notre
société on aime bien la stabilité et on
nous apprend à patienter on y dit
souvent que nos rêves
il faut les recouvrir avec un petit
mouchoir les maîtres bien au fond de
notre poche
parce qu'avant tout il faut réussir sa
vie avoir un mari un métier des enfants
des loisirs je n'ai pas voulu attendre
j'ai préféré réaliser maintenant mes
rêves en prenant le risque de me cogner
plein de fois mais en apprenant toujours
c'est cette logique qui m'a amené à
franchir la ligne d'arrivée d'une course
à la voile mythique la route du rhum
transatlantique en solitaire qui relie
saint malo à pointe à pitre en
guadeloupe il y a deux ans et celle de
la transat jacques vabre l'année
dernière
en préparant cette qu'on fait
ans j'ai pris le temps de remonter le
temps et je me suis demandé ce qui à ma
petite échelle m'avait déjà permis de
réaliser plusieurs de mes plus grands
rêves
est ce qu'il y a une recette et quels en
sont les ingrédients
je suis né il y à 34 ans à tous j'ai
grandi en banlieue de la ville dans un
petit immeuble
j'ai tout de suite été fasciné par le
monde animal je ramenais à l'appartement
toutes les bêtes possibles et
imaginables et au grand dam de mes
parents je les ai levé les remettez sur
pied et leur faisait faire des petits
à un moment il y a eu plus de 1000
phasmes les petits insectes brindille
dans ma chambre et même 10 poulet quand
j'ai enfin réussi à bricoler une
couveuse alors autant dire que j'étais
prédestiné à être vétérinaire
j'ai travaillé dur pour réussir ce
concours et j'ai fini par faire de ma
première passion mon métier
durant mes études je n'ai pas voulu
abandonner mes autres rêves notamment
celui de monter à cheval
même si je n'en avais pas les moyens
alors j'ai créé une association pour
m'occuper des vieux chevaux de travaux
pratiques de l'école vétérinaire et de
fil en aiguille de rencontre en
rencontre
j'ai fini par m'entraîner comme jockey
et courir sur un des plus grands
hippodromes parisiens
mon rêve de petite fille fascinées par
les talons noirs été réalisés
j'ai commencé à travailler comme
vétérinaire à la campagne à 23 ans les
vêlages la nuit les veaux a sauvé la
satisfaction des éleveurs j'étais
contente de réussir à être levés tôt de
campagne dont tout le monde parle avec
amour et voilà au bout de quelques
années d'exercice
je me suis vite rendu compte qu'il était
difficile de faire cohabiter travail et
rêve je me surprenais de plus en plus
souvent au volant de ma voiture entre
deux visites à regarder l'horizon et à
me dire il faut que je vois autre chose
alors en 2008 j'ai tenté quelque chose
de différent
j'ai mis pour la première fois mon pied
sur un bateau lors d'un stage à l'ucp à
la mer me fascine et m'a tiré mais me
faisait peur aussi
j'avais dévoré tous les récits de marins
bombard chez kelton tabarly miles davis
ellen macarthur et cette fois c'était
moi qui étais en mer entourée d'eau de
ciel et de dauphins ça a été un
véritable coup de foudre
j'ai alors décidé de quitter les
montagnes les aveyronnaises où je
travaillais à l'époque pour rejoindre
l'océan et j'ai atterri à vannes en
octobre 2009 ou après quelques stages de
voile j'ai rapidement passer mon
monitorat
je me suis inscrite dans les bourse aux
équipiers
les capitaineries des ports et j'ai
ainsi pu me perfectionner à moindre coût
j'ai également trouvé un travail à
mi-temps comme vétérinaire mais je ne
pensais plus qu'à une chose navigué
pendant trois ans j'ai fait toutes les
régates possible
j'ai accepté tout les convoyages qu'on
me proposait j'ai ainsi pu rencontrer
d'autres passionnés et grâce à ces
rencontres
je suis parti de plus en plus au large
angleterre espagne açores et puis en
décembre 2012
je pars sur ma première transatlantique
en équipage nous sommes quatre sur un
vieux bateau classique en bois j'ai
quitté mon appartement j'ai quitté mon
job de vétérinaire j'ai mis mes affaires
en garde meuble je suis libre prête pour
l'aventuré
la course a été magique
je rentre en avril 2013
à vannes chez une amie sans boulot sans
logement la tête pleine de course de
bateaux et de mère je suis un peu perdu
je ne veux pas retourner à ma vie
d'avant mais je n'ai pas les moyens de
m'offrir un bateau et de partir en mer
c'est alors en juillet 2013 que je fais
une rencontre qui va changer ma vie je
me rends à quimper à une soirée d'amis
d'amis à laquelle je ne devais pas aller
c'est là que je rencontre bertrand de
broc
le marin célèbre pour s'être recousu la
langue tout seul lors d'un de savoie de
l'ain lors d'un de ces vendée globe
il cherche un matelot pour le lendemain
matin je saute sur l'occasion et les
deux jours suivants j'ai un second coup
de foudre
les bateaux de course au large rapide
magnifique tout me semble fluide à bord
tout me semble simple
c'est bertrand qui me parle de la route
du rhum qui part l'année suivante
alors évidemment je rigole je n'ai fait
qu'une seule transatlantique en équipe
hier je n'ai jamais navigué seule encore
moins sur un bateau de course
je n'ai aucune connaissance dans le
milieu et surtout je n'ai plus aucun sou
je ne travaille plus comme vétérinaire
j'ai juste de quoi vivre quelques mois
avec l'argent que j'ai mis de côté je me
rappelle alors le début de l'été lors
d'une semaine de régates en angleterre à
cause ou je suis équipé un numéro 1 sur
un magnifique voilier
lorsque le maître à bord est arrivée et
a déclaré que ça serait un bateau
entièrement masculin je me suis retrouvé
casey comme vous je trouve sur un autre
bateau anglais où je ne comprenais rien
alors en réfléchissant à ce que me
disait bertrand j'ai compris que je
pouvais devenir le commandant de mon
propre bateau et retrouver les mêmes
sensations que sur son voilier être
indépendante
pour cela il me fallait un projet fou la
transatlantique la plus connue du monde
la route du rhum et trouver des sponsors
pour la faire avec le recul
à cette époque si je ne l'avais pas
rencontrée je n'aurais jamais osé penser
à la route du rhum mais il a cru en moi
et il m'a donné confiance et ça a changé
ma vie alors mi août 2013
je rentre chez moi seul un énorme poids
sur les épaules parce que je le sais je
vais le faire mais comment faire comment
trouver 240000 euros en moins d'un an
d'ailleurs comment on trouve un sponsor
et puis comment ça marche le sponsoring
et puis d'ailleurs mais quels bateaux
doivent trouver alors je me suis demandé
mais qui peut m'aider à créer une telle
entreprise
j'ai alors été demandé conseil à
l'ancien chef d'entreprise qui possédait
le bateau sur lequel je venais de
traverser l'atlantique
il s'est tout de suite enthousiasmé et
grâce à lui et aux autres équipiers qui
étaient à bord
nous avons démarré le projet il mon
coach et pour créer ma société
travailler l'image et la communication
et surtout m'organiser pour la recherche
des sponsors
grâce à eux nous avons bâti les
fondations du projet et ils m'ont aidé à
bâtir des supports de communication
drôle c'est décalé
je me rends compte qu'à cette époque mon
projet n'aurait pas vu le jour si je
n'avais pas osé en parler autour de moi
je n'ai pas eu peur d'être ridicule et
je n'ai pas eu peur de demander de
l'aide
et j'ai rencontré des gens
extraordinaires qui me l'ont rendu au
centuple
alors beaucoup de marins rêve de faire
la route du rhum tous n'y arrive pas et
encore moins de femmes au départ du rhum
en 2014
nous sommes seulement quatre femmes sur
93 partant moi ça ne fait que quatre ans
que j'ai découvert la voile et je n'ai
aucune connaissance dans le milieu je me
demande comment je peux être plus
convaincante que tous ces marins
aguerris pour enthousiasmer un sponsor
on s'est alors dit deux choses
premièrement il fallait faire
différemment ne pas copier tous ces
marins parce que ça ne marchera pas pour
moi prendre en considération les
différences et les tourné à mon avantage
j'ai alors tout accès sur ma profession
vétérinaire qui me rendait différente
des autres
et puis deuxièmement si j'arrivais à
m'aligner sur la ligne de départ de la
route du rhum avec mon bagage nautique
de débutants on parle rémois est sûre et
les sponsors aurait un retour sur
investissement le pari était imposé
concrètement j'ai eu l'idée de commencer
avec une campagne de communication
complètement décalé avec les animaux les
animaux soutiennent une veto sur
l'atlantique cela m'a permis la une du
journal local ouest france dans ma
région et cela m'a permis de me
constituer un fan-club animalier omar le
homard marie-jo la poule cacahuètes le
lapin kitty le cochon d'inde hannibal le
chat jacquotte la chèvre et des
centaines d'autres m'ont permis de
croire en mon projet
pour continuer dans le côté décalé je me
suis rendu au salon de l'agriculture à
paris avec mon tableau weleda et mon
appareil photo je voulais faire
participer les éleveurs et leurs bêtes à
ma course
sur cette photo on me voit au stand d'un
fromage très réputé avec un agneau
lacaune la race qui fait ce fromage
célèbre et quelques mois plus tard on
retrouve ce fromage sur ma grand voile
alors à force de centaines de mails de
coups de fil de rencontres
je fini par décrocher les premiers
rendez-vous et finalement au bout de
quatre mois en janvier 2014
j'ai trois premiers gros sponsors dans
le milieu du monde animal et rural j'ai
réuni un tiers du budget environ 80000
euros
je me rends compte à cette époque qu'en
restant candide
en intégrant ce milieu qui n'était pas
le mien ça a finalement fonctionné
en fait j'ai fait de mes faiblesses des
différences et de mes différences j'en
ai fait des points forts fin mars 2014
j'ai enfin trouvé le bateau 7,1 class40
anglais magnifique et très bien équipée
je n'ai pas tout à fait assez d'argent
pour le louer je le loue quand même la
prise en main du bolide en solitaire fut
rocambolesque et je me rappellerai
longtemps ma sortie du port de la
trinité sur mer où je pars à l'aube pour
que personne ne me voit hisser la
grand-voile en mettant un temps fou
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai réalisé
que j'étais seul sans expérience et sans
le budget à devoir assumer ma société
mes premiers sponsors le bateau à mettre
en chantier les paperasses réussir mes
courses qualificatives
j'ai vu une montagne et j'ai cru sombré
avec le navire je n'ai pas eu le choix
j'ai décidé de ne plus regarder
l'ensemble des problèmes mais de
m'atteler à les résoudre
un nains j'ai fait des listes des
tableaux excel et mon but à chaque matin
bart et le maximum de lignes
j'ai ainsi passer toutes les épreuves
qualificatives
entre avril et juin 2014 et j'ai
surmonté mes problèmes de budget au jour
le jour
tout d'abord en faisant une crotte
funding une plateforme de financement
participatif sur internet puis en
faisant un petit emprunt à la banque
sous caution évidemment parce que la
banque ne voulait pas me prêter
j'ai ainsi pu tenir jusqu'à l'été alors
début juillet 2014
je suis qualifié est inscrite pour la
rue du rhône j'ai un bateau magnifique
mais voilà je n'ai plus aucun sou je
suis face au mur si je ne paye pas les
prochaines traite de location du bateau
fin août je dois le rendre à son
propriétaire anglais
j'ai l'impression d'avoir tout essayé
claude funding art phoning banques
amis famille je dois faire différemment
mais je ne vois pas comment alors je
pars quelques jours faire du yoga ce que
je suis un peu comme un paquet nerfs
contracter les deux premiers jours je ne
peux plus bouger tellement j'ai des
courbatures et le troisième jour je
respire enfin
je reviens mais c'est l'été la france
est en sommeil
tous mes coups de fils tombe à l'eau
alors début août désespéré je me dis
quitte à perdre mon bateau autant aller
naviguer et puis tenté une dernière
chose aller à saint malo
c'est la ville du départ il s'y passera
peut-être quelque chose sinon cap sur
l'angleterre pour tenter de renégocier
le contrat de location du bateau mi août
un an pile après ma décision de faire la
route du rhum j'arrive à saint malo avec
mon bateau je le garde devant la vieille
ville et je tente de vendre mes t-shirts
aimé autocollants sur les pontons
c'est un échec les deux premiers jours
je vends un autocollant à 2 euros et le
troisième jour seulement trois
tee-shirts
alors c'est pas faute d'utiliser tous
nos atouts mais je ne passe pas inaperçu
et au bout de quelques jours un petit
sponsor singh pour 3000 euros mais
surtout je fais une belle rencontre
un skipper amis d'amis vient de perdre
son bateau sur lequel il doit faire la
route du rhum
il lui reste son sponsor alors que je
largue les amarres pour l'angleterre il
me prévient qu'il va le contact et le
lendemain matin tandis que jacques coste
à southampton
je reçois un appel son sponsor veux bien
me rencontrer ni une ni deux je
retraverse et finalement j'ai signé avec
le plus gros partenaire de mon projet je
me rends compte qu'en étant restés dans
l'action en ayant tenté de nouvelles
choses j'ai pas eu ce que je comptais
obtenir j'ai eu beaucoup plus beaucoup
mieux si je n'avais pas agi à ce moment
là je pense que je serais resté à quai
alors début septembre grâce à ce nouveau
sponsor je peux enfin m'entraîner
sérieusement je demande à thomas ruyant
dernier vainqueur de la route du rhum de
m'entraîner et je prend aussi des cours
de météo avec un excellent coureur du
circuit figaro
mais voilà il me manque toujours
cinquante mille euros
alors fin septembre lors de la
présentation officielle des skippers à
paris le présentateur explique ma
situation devant les 500 personnes de
l'auditoire et le soir même je signe
avec une agence immobilière pour la fin
du budget après un an de course contre
la montre mon budget bouclé un mois
avant le départ le 2 novembre
je me rappelle le million de personnes
sur les pontons avant le départ
et toujours cette même exclamations mais
quel courage de partir sur l'atlantique
seule une fille en plus et moi mais je
ne savais pas quoi répondre tellement ça
me paraissait évident le courage c'était
avant qu'il m'en fallait parce que là je
ne veux plus qu'une chose partir je ne
vous referai pas vivre toute la course
au jour le jour parce qu'il faudrait un
autre tedx je suis arrivé 19e sur 43
concurrents de ma catégorie en 19 jours
je retiens avec émotion quelques images
le départ dans un état second où je suis
malade mais teigneuse non je ne lâcherai
rien faut-il y aller à la rame
j'irai jusqu'au bout les heures le soir
seul face à la mer avec la sensation
d'être de plus en plus en accord avec
mon bateau comme si c'était un animal et
l'arrivée qui restent jusqu'à
aujourd'hui le plus beau jour de ma vie
alors est ce qu'il existe une recette
pour réussir un pari fou en remontant le
temps je retiens cinq grandes leçons qui
m'ont permis de gagner ce pari et qui
peuvent être réutilisables pour beaucoup
d'entre nous et pour tout projet qu'on
essaie le rêve est né de la confiance
qu'on m'a donné
le ridicule ne m'a pas tué mais m'a aidé
j'ai transformé mes faiblesses en point
fort j'ai oublié que je n'avais aucune
chance
et quand plus rien ne me sens des
monnaies ne m'a semblé possible
j'ai agi quand je relis ces ingrédients
entre eux je le revois un point commun
une certaine candeur un refus de prendre
en compte ce que nous appelons tous la
réalité cela m'a permis d'aller au delà
des contraintes matérielles financières
et psychique que l'on se met ou que l'on
nous met naturellement j'aimerais
conclure cette conférence avec une
citation extraite d'un film célèbre les
bronzés font du ski
parce que comme jean claude dusse
j'aimerais vous dire oublie que c'est
impossible
vas-y fonce
[Applaudissements]